at this point Pat smear had joined the
band too that was a huge like from the
release of the album he was touring with
you guys this was it was big because we
had made the album and Kurt had talked
about you know at one point there was a
second guitarist in Nirvana before I
joined the band and he wanted to get
another guitarist at this point and he
says um he goes down to Los Angeles he
comes back he says I found our second
guitar player and he said really who's
that he said Pat smear from the germs M
and if anybody knows the germs they were
very early on the punk rock band in Los
Angeles perhaps the most dangerous and
um so I just thought like oh my God I
can't believe that guy's still
alive because he was in the germs and
also and and a side a sad side note is
side note is like Darby Darby Crash yeah
he committed suicide yeah the singer of
the
germs um anyway so Pat comes up and I'm
just expecting this big disgusting fat
junkie and he's the most
wonderful
energetic brilliant beautiful put
together he he he really breathed this
whole new life into the band the great
thing too is I there's a great anecdote
that
defines his contribution to the band In
addition to being a great musician and
and and I think what I've always read is
that Kurt wanted someone who could also
help handle some of the you know
technical parts so that he could focus
more on the performance and the and and
singing and so obviously P can do that
but the other thing that was a great is
that he had this uh great attitude and
there was a story of you guys playing a
show and then there's a not a nice
review about the show and it says you
know the show was off and someone's
reading the
review people are getting pissed that
was the first sorry to interrupt the
first night of the the opening night of
the tour the inudo tour was at the
Arizona State Fair and it's the first
night
and so you know it takes a couple shows
to get roll in and so it was Edna
Gunderson from USA Today Shez
Louise a name that will
live she gave us a mediocre review like
why didn't she go like three or four
shows into the tour then she would have
caught us and that's what you get on
this um box set you get the band is at
full what happens is this review comes
out and the story I heard uh is that the
the review comes out and everyone on the
bus is like God damn it why did USA
Today write this about us and Pat said
oh come on we sucked and everybody
laughed meaning just sort
of taking taking the piss out of the
whole thing come on we were off well you
know well also I love that who do you
call to take over the technical side of
things in a guitar band the guy
from the germs yeah I can't think of a I
can't think of a band that is a a a
closer parallel to the kind of like
uneasy feeling that you got from the
weirdest moments of Nirvana than the
germs like their their their whole thing
had that same sort of yeah like familiar
but slightly Sleazy and slightly
uncomfortable quality and and it was a
Sonic thing like the sound of Pat sme's
guitar it sounded a little sour and a
little you know a little creepy and it
seemed like a like it was a natural as
soon as I heard about it I thought oh
yeah that's a natural it was it was
great so when we came out to do these
shows I mean they were bigger shows and
I mean really it was our first Arena
tour you know when did you like was did
you like playing the Arenas it it felt
strange at first I think I mean I
towards the end of 1991 we did an arena
Tour opening up for the Red Hot Chili
Peppers and um you know I I was always
afraid that that what we did that energy
wouldn't translate in a in a bigger room
y you know cuz we were used to playing
places this big and put us in the corner
there and the place explodes and it's
amazing to try to you know move that
yeah to a bigger room would be hard so
um it felt weird all of a sudden there
was like Caterers yeah we had a caterer
on tour and then the catering fired them
because they made the wrong mac and
cheese well no because they did because
they had really good food I thought it
was really good and Kurt like corn dogs
and macaroni and cheese and our baloney
sandwiches so they were making actual
Macar
with actual cheese and he had never had
that before and that was the last
straw you know so it was just
like you know was one of those things
like ah and well we did a show we had a
show it was a 90-minute show we had a
stage set up we would do our acoustic
breakdown part yeah we did the same show
every
night um and we would play it was like
$20 tickets tickets were like 20 bucks
because you could sell CDs and make
money and then we had like working
family prices but then also the best
part was we're like oh okay we're in
Arena band now right cool the opening
band is going to be the boredoms from
Japan or the opening band is going to be
the Butthole Surfers so You' got
all these kids that like just bought
their Nirvana T-shirt and they come to
The Rock Show to see their favorite band
and they've got like Bobcat gwe is the
MC and then the Butthole Surfers
like what the is going on how did
Bobcat gold weight become the opener for
you guys were real fans we were fans
Kurt had meet Bob that record and then
we just so happened to be it was like in
1990 and I we were in like Michigan or
Wisconsin at a college radio station and
Bobcat was there and we like hey we know
you he didn't know who we were we nobody
knew who we were like hey we you're
you're on Police Academy like we're
like and he he tells the story he goes
say yeah I met them and I said good luck
with your little
band as we said goodbye
and then we just yeah I don't know we
just got he was sort of on our side like
as as as a comedian sure he was like
kind of a cynical subversive
weirdo yeah yeah and so we liked him and
he got a bad riew Rex Reed gave him a
bad review and he goes he was my f
favorite judge on The Gong
[Laughter]
Show